hey guys Pete here Westworld season 1
episode 6 has come and gone and this
will be my recap gonna go through it
scene by scene and then talk about some
thoughts it brings up around the major
storylines it will contain spoilers
about everything that's happened in West
world so far if you aren't caught up
with what's been happening through
episode 6 you'll probably want to stop
watching now so let's jump right into it
we started out with May waking up the
last time we saw her she had woken up in
the center and freaked out the text when
the bird landed on her finger we see her
walk into the mariposa and can tell she
has something on her mind a new guest
comes in and she tells Clementine she'll
take this one she takes him upstairs
where she starts insulting him as soon
as they get into the room he starts to
have sex with her and we realized she is
goading him in order to have him kill
her puts his hand on her throat and she
encourages him to start choking we start
to see her lose consciousness and then
we see her wake up in the center she
sees Felix the tech we last saw her with
and she says now then where were we
Bernard is in his office where we last
saw him with Elsie it seems like no time
has passed since he is just picking up
the satellite link they discussed the
fact that someone inside the center must
have been planted the device and talk
strategy to figure out how to learn who
actually put it there Bernard explains
that the stray was an older model so the
data wasn't completely gone she asked
what they're gonna do and he says he has
to go downstairs we see him in the
elevator where he gets to the floor
be 82 which is restricted the elevator
tells him as much and uses name to gain
access he enters the floor where things
look to be abandoned we see some of the
mechanical parts from the early host and
this could even be the area where we saw
the young doctor for a few episodes back
one thing that stuck out when he turned
on his flashlight was this host if you
ever watch the original movie it almost
looks like your Brenner's character he
was the host that went rogue in the
movie so it's an interesting little
throwback anyways Bernard finds the
computer terminal and logs in it looks
more contemporary than the folding
computers they use now but can't really
necessarily decide when it's from either
he pairs this computer to scan for
anomalies and the straw
comes up right away he sends the info to
LC and then the old computer tells him
it found five more anomalies bernard
looks at it as lost as I am trying to
figure out what this is so he looks a
little deeper he finds out that there
are five more hosts that aren't
registered with the new system in a
remote area of the park what that means
isn't clear but you can see that he's
definitely thinking hard about it
whenever the scene ends in the small
Mexican town where Laurence is from we
see things stopped as dr. Ford arrives
with some of his assistants they tell
him they would have to level the town to
extend the canyon where he wanted it but
he says that they can just stop it
before the city he then tells them he'll
find his own way back wakes all the
hosts up and has a look around he
notices the maze carved into a table
where some of the men are playing
dominoes we next see him in his office
where he's looking at a model of the new
city work with the white church from the
new narrative he gets up and grabs an
old sketch book from a cabinet we see
the early drawings of Dolores and then
he turns the page there we see the
sketch of the maze which is a big clue
that the mazes is old as Dolores and
that means Arnold was involved we
already knew this for the most part but
still showing these two things together
like that implies that there may be a
deeper connection between the oldest
host in the park and the idea of the
maze the man in black is riding with
Teddy towards pariah he has the scalp
with the maze on his lap and Teddy and
he notices that Teddy takes a look at it
he asked him if that looks like anything
to him and Teddy replies that there
isn't much to say it's an old myth of
the natives the man in blacks tells him
to go ahead and regale him and this is
the description of the myth that Teddy
tells him the maze itself is the sum of
a man's life choices he makes dreams he
hangs on to and there at the center
there's a legendary man that's been
killed over and over again countless
times but always caused his himself back
to life the man returned for the last
time and vanquished all of his
oppressors in a tireless fury he built a
house and around that house he built a
maze so complicated only he could get
through it I reckon he'd seen enough of
fighting after the talk two men come
along on the road to tell him the army
of
shut down the border because there was
trouble in pariah the man in black asked
Teddy if he knows another way across the
border what she does
he says it's treacherous but he's going
either way to find Dolores the man in
black has his opportunity and follows
along felix is explaining to Maeve that
she's made by the engineers upstairs and
despite having much superior processing
power compared to humans that there is
one major drawback she is under their
control she doesn't believe this so he
pairs his computer with her we get this
really great sequence where she sees her
decision-making process in real time on
the screen it freaks her out and she
shuts down while experiencing a crash
Bernard visits Teresa in her office
where she's sitting there looking
pensive he says he needs a word but she
changes the subject to start talking
about how Ford knows about their
relationship she basically breaks it off
with him saying it can't go on and when
Bernard says he can be impartial she
reveals the real reason she needs to do
it
she doesn't think he's impartial when it
comes to Ford and it seems clear that
she's going to recommend that the board
remove the doctor really soon she needs
to get rid of any leverage for it has
over her like her relationship with
Bernard before she makes her move
felix is frantically trying to get made
back online which he eventually does we
get one of the best sequences of the
season where she tells him she wants to
go upstairs he says no but she uses her
persuasive programming to convince him
and she gives this amazing sly smile
once she knows she has it he takes her
on a tour pretending that he's testing
her or something like that I guess she
sees Depp you know several different
areas where the hosts are being
developed and we get a really cool shot
of a new host having their blood
inserted for the first time and we see
the body go from the white color to the
flesh color they go through design where
he tries to get her back on to the
elevator to go back downstairs before
she does she sees a giant screen where
they're playing the welcome message that
we saw William you know with when he
first came she sees herself on the
screen and an old narrative walking with
her daughter this freaks her out and she
wants to know how they have her dreams
back downstairs he explains that they
weren't dreams but that they reassigned
the house all the time
he's in the middle of explaining how it
works when the douchey tack shows back
up and asked what's going on
he threatens a tournament and Maeve
springs into action she grabs a scalpel
and holds it to his throat
she expertly reasons with him that he
doesn't want to die so he should do what
she says the scene ends with Sylvester
whimpering but it looks like Maeve has
convinced him to play along we get a
quick shot of Teresa in her office
talking to someone important online he's
speaking in Asian language so we don't
know what he says but she ends the
conversation by saying yes she
understands the urgency she lights up a
cigarette while looking down on the
hologram of the park as the scene cuts
away next we see her approach Lea
Sizemore who's drinking at a pool wall
on sick leave she tells him that she
needs him back at work and he whines
about how much work went into the
narrative that Ford destroyed she says
that there are continuity holes and
several stories because of his pulling
hosts for the new narrative and she
needs him to fix it she explains that a
Ford can't pull it off they'll be
looking to replace him but they won't be
looking at the pool the man in black is
concerned with Teddy's choice of border
crossing he tells them he needs him
alive and knows he'll get killed if they
try to shoot their way through the
soldiers who are guarding the tunnel to
the old territories as they're talking
he sees two soldiers by themselves which
he realizes he can kill to take their
uniforms dressed as soldiers they
approach the border but a soldier
recognizes Teddy from the past
Teddy ends up shooting him and some
others but they get captured in the
process Lea still at the pool and eyes
up a guess that he wants to chat up from
this I gather he is at the Mesa Gold the
area where you go to decompress from
your stay in the park it's like a buffer
zone that you visit before you go back
to the real world anyways he tries to
order a drink while he's talking and the
bartender cuts him off he delivers a
message that Teresa wants him to sober
up and get back to work the guest leaves
at this but Lee decides to grab a bottle
from behind the bar when the bartender
isn't looking he says [ __ ] this place
and takes off with it
Elsie comes to tell Bernard that the
tracking data he sent her was
time-stamped she says she'll be able to
find out who the saboteur is she says
she's going to use this as a way to get
ahead with corporate once they
find out she saved them from this
espionage she goes on a rant about
Theresa saying hers will be the first
head to roll and we see that Bernard is
torn between what's going on he takes
off to the control center and looks at
Teresa in her office when he goes past
he finds a tech and asked her about his
inquiry
she says the sector he asked about has
been deserted since it is being held for
future expansions he asked if any hosts
or tests have been there and she says no
he goes on his own to this sector and
finds a house on the property when he
enters we see the boy that Ford was
talking to and we see a man that looks
like Arnold from the picture Ford showed
him the man gets angry when he asked if
he's Arnold and starts to grab him in
order to throw him out of the house
Bernard tries to stop him but he doesn't
respond to his voice commands for shows
up and stops him and explains that they
are the only original hosts that Arnold
built himself left in the park
he tells Bernard he told Arnold the
story about a family getaway as a child
that was his one happy memory from
childhood Arnold made these hosts as a
gift for him and he kept it and
maintained them himself when all the
hosts got upgraded the boy is him as a
child and the rest are his family but
Bernard says it's dangerous to have them
for shows him that he is you know has
complete control of any asprin our to
overlook what he saw he says you would
want to see your son again if you could
and Bernard seems to be okay with that
he says he needs to get back and Ford
says they can talk about it later if he
likes we see Stubbs at the center saying
they need to keep an eye on pariah at
the same time Lee shows up drunk and
starts pissing on the mat from above
Teresa comes up to him and he talks some
[ __ ] before realizing she's with someone
else he founds out the woman at the bar
wasn't a guest but a person from
corporate that is there to look things
over Bernard is that behavior and is
asking the computer about
first-generation host he asked how many
there are and how many Arnold made
himself we find out there were 82 and
that Arnold built 47 of them
he asked for a list of all first
generations hosts that are still in
rotation and we see it scroll by on a
screen we see Dolores there but not much
else to tell us what he's looking at at
the tunnel Teddy and the man in black
are tied up the soldiers were heating
a brand of the maze that they intend to
give teddy
the man in black tries to bargain with
them but they aren't having it as they
hold the brand to Teddy's chest he has a
flashback and we see that he actually
was was killing his own men with Wyatt
the man about to brand him calls him a
killer which he basically agrees with
and then he slips out of the ropes he's
tied up with and grabs the brand he
starts knocking people out and the man
in black starts shooting them
Teddy jumps behind a Gatling gun and
starts killing every soldier in sight
once he's finished he tells the man in
black let's get the horses and gear and
move on else he calls Bernard to tell
him it is one of Dallas's satellites
they found she tells him she's going to
check out a transmitter that was turned
on to see who else accessed it she tells
him that the voices the hosts are
hearing her being broadcast from there
and he says they abandoned doing that
years ago she's talking about the
bicameral mind thing and he doesn't
really know what to think about it Ford
walks up on his young self and tells him
that he wants to play catch with the
doll the boy looks upset so he asked him
where the dog is when they get there
they can see that the dog is dead and
his bloody around the head mouth
Elsie shows up at the abandoned theater
that looks like something straight out
of a horror movie she scans around until
she finds the relay she downloads the
information about previous users but we
don't see what she finds
Bernard shows up at Teresa's apartment
to tell her what he's found he ignores
one call from Elsie and starts to tell
Teresa something about Ford and Arnold
Elsie calls again so he has to answer
she tells him that Teresa is the one
who's been uploading the data but
there's more
he says he'll have to call her back and
we won't we don't see how he handles the
rest of the conversation with Teresa
before leaving Felix and Sylvester
explaining how Maeve's personality is
determined and they're showing her how
she's program they show her the
attribute matrix and she isn't happy
about her intelligence rating they
explained she is as high as they let any
host go but she still says she wants to
make some changes when Sylvester tries
to explain that they can't do that Maeve
turns things around once again saying
that the lonely boys down there can do
exactly that they can activate host and
race their minds she implicates that
he's been using this to pimp her out
while she was in for repairs but she'll
forego her cut for some alterations he
takes the computer and sits down and
appears to be making the changes she
wants bernard finds a place to call
elsie back said that he can learn what
else she's found she tells him that
Teresa was using the old bicameral mind
control system to reprogram the stray
she says that someone else has been
using the system for weeks making major
changes to retask them they've been
making changes to their prime directives
which means they could lie to the staff
or even hurt them when he asked who's
making the changes she says the best she
can tell is that it's Arnold he points
out the obvious fact that Arnold is dead
to which she replies he's a prolific
coder for a dead guy she says she'll
transfer all the data and bring it to
him and he says he'll be at his office
ford is interrogating his young self in
his office about what happened with the
dog he finds out the boy is lying by
putting him in analysis mode he pushes
to find out why he killed it and the boy
says a voice told him to when he asked
whose voice he says Arnold he says the
boys told him that he could help the dog
it was a killer but it wasn't its fault
if he killed the dog the dog wouldn't be
able to kill anything yes Ford looks
troubled by this and we can see that him
keeping the old host may be a future
problem Elsie is transferring and
looking over the data in the creepy
abandoned theater and she hears a noise
behind her she gets up to look around
and as she says the name Arnold someone
grabs her from behind
Sylvester tells made their in and that
she's up as they are lowering her
loyalty felix notices that someone else
has already been altering her attributes
so lester says it's someone with a much
higher privileges than him and that he's
done she turns things around once more
and then tells felix to turn her bulk at
perception all the way up he does and
she says dear boys were going to have
some fun aren't we and with that the
episode ends if you were wondering what
the specific term they used for her
intelligence metric like what it means
well so was I and
to look it up and I found that the
dictionary definition of the word at
perception is as follows one
introspective self-consciousness to
mental perception especially the process
of understanding something perceived in
terms of previous experience so that's
pretty much up for the episode can we
take a minute to talk about just how
amazing the actress Thandie Newton is
the opening sequence alone is just
superior acting every gesture and move
she makes is like perfect we noticed
that she was on a getting killed spree
but we learned that it was more of an
attempt to figure out what was going on
rather than her actually knowing what to
expect when she woke up on the other
side the scene with her walking through
the center kind of discovering all this
stuff could have been really bad because
obviously it's far fetched that he can
take her take her around without them
getting caught but the way it was put
together and her acting actually made it
work so what is going on with the five
unregistered host of a family that
Bernard is keeping off the grid
the cover story he tell like he feeds
Bernard seems to check out based on the
scene where he talks to the boy about
the dog to me I felt like he was trying
to understand his own path past
transgressions through the hose and
seemed genuinely concerned when the boy
told him about the voices but why did
his father look like the picture that he
showed Bernard of Arnold it seemed to
play the role of an overbearing father
figure is there more to this honestly
Arnold seemed made up to me when they
first brought him up but each week the
story gets more involved which makes it
hard to believe that he might not be a
real person at the same time if this is
some big thing that he's doing to spice
things up with his new narrative he's
doing a really good job the introduction
of the maize meth is interesting is it
literal as if there's a host at the
center as part of a narrative or is it a
true myth started by Arnold himself who
hid away in the park rather than dying
did he hide from dr. Ford and is the man
in black the key to getting him or is
that just dumb because obviously
anything that guests could do dr. Ford
would have figured out how to do a long
time ago it's a bit confusing but we
still have four episodes left
so I'm sure that we're gonna get more
hints in that direction the main thing
is it doesn't line up with him looking
at that old sketchbook or paying
attention to the carving of the maze on
the table if Ford is actually behind all
the main stuff that's popping up he's
doing a pretty good job of deceiving us
like I said he's a really calm and
collected character which is also a nod
to how good of an actor Anthony Hopkins
is but he seems to be worked up when you
think about it along those lines it's
cool to see Teddy break out and go just
go crazy with improvisation when he
thinks Dolores is in trouble the Gatling
gun scene shocked even the man in black
who is basically pulling his strings
right now this could really come in
handy when they move across the border
and it's interesting to see the guy who
was always getting killed before now
taking a you know an active role in
killing other people we gotta know
Dolores at all this episode but they are
headed in her direction her and William
were last seen on the train headed to
the front which could potentially be
where Wyatt is at this point we know for
sure he's not in Paria so they're a
little behind but if you watch the
trailer from last week you know what I'm
aiming at here Felix and Sylvester are
so far over their heads here with Maeve
and they're improving her think about it
she had them both eating out of her hand
before the upgrade now she's a full six
points higher than they'd let any host
go in a perception I don't think it's a
coincidence that Felix mentioned that
the hosts have more processing power
than humans and then later ended up
maxing her out after seeing everything
she saw would we consider her conscious
I mean she understands what she is and
how her universe works
she's almost skipped right over normal
consciousness and transcended it at this
point with her improved skills she
should be able to do whatever she wants
the big question now is what would a
host actually want what will she do with
these newfound powers so to speak she
seems a little resentful at the
situation she's in right now but will
she go down in a blaze of glory taking
it out on the park or will she aim for
something else like maybe leaving the
park I'm curious to hear what you guys
think about all this stuff so let me
know in the comments I really liked how
this episode was more character based
and how the story moved along
in a different way it was almost a
different show almost but I think it was
a good transition from some of the
heavier stuff Dolores is going through I
guess the difference in core coding has
them going for the same destination with
two different journeys which is pretty
exciting when you think about it I don't
know it is for me anyways and I can't
wait to see how the last four episodes
play out please like the video if you
liked it and make sure to subscribe to
my channel to keep up with my latest
videos if you're a game of Thrones fan
I'm doing a book giveaway with those
videos so check out one of them and you
can learn all about it thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon